We now introduce normal random
variables, which are also
often called Gaussian
random variables.
Normal random variables are
perhaps the most important
ones in probability theory.
They play a key role in the
theory of the subject, as we
will see later in this class in
the context of the central
limit theorem.
They're also prevalent in
applications for two reasons.
They have some nice analytical
properties, and they're are
also the most common model
of random noise.
In general, they are a good
model of noise or randomness
whenever that noise is due to
the addition of many small
independent noise terms, and
this is a very common
situation in the real world.
We define normal random
variables by specifying their
PDFs, and we start with the
simplest case of the so-called
standard normal.
The standard normal is indicated
with this shorthand
notation, and we will see
shortly why this notation is
being used.
It is defined in
terms of a PDF.
This PDF is defined for
all values of x. x
can be any real number.
So this random variable
can take values
anywhere on the real line.
And the formula for the
PDF is this one.
Let us try to understand
this formula.
So we have the exponential of
negative x squared over 2.
Now, if we are to plot the x
squared over 2 function, it
has a shape of this form, and
it is centered at zero.
But then we take the negative
exponential of this function.
Now, when you take the negative
exponential, whenever
this thing is big, the negative
exponential is going
to be small.
So the negative exponential
would be equal to 1 when x is
equal to 0.
But then as x increases,
because x squared also
increases, the negative
exponential will fall off.
And so we obtain a shape of this
kind, and symmetrically
on the other side as well.
And finally, there
is this constant.
Where [is] this constant
coming from?
Well there's a nice and not
completely straightforward
calculus exercise that tells
us that the integral from
minus infinity to plus infinity
of e to the negative
x squared over 2, dx, is equal
to the square root of 2 pi.
Now, we need a PDF to
integrates to 1.
And so for this to happen, this
is the constant that we
need to put in front of this
expression so that the
integral becomes 1, and that
explains the presence of this
particular constant.
What is the mean of this
random variable?
Well, x squared is symmetric
around 0, and for this reason,
the PDF itself is symmetric
around 0.
And therefore, by symmetry, the
mean has to be equal to 0.
And that explains
this entry here.
How about the variance?
Well, to calculate the variance,
you need to solve a
calculus problem again.
You need to integrate
by parts.
And after you carry out the
calculation, then you find
that the variance is equal to
1, and that explains this
entry here in the notation
that we have been using.
Let us now define general
normal random variables.
General normal random variables
are once more
specified in terms of the
corresponding PDF, but this
PDF is a little more
complicated, and it involves
two parameters--
mu and sigma squared,
where sigma is a
given positive parameter.
Once more, it will have a bell
shape, but this bell is no
longer symmetric around 0, and
there is some control over the
width of it.
Let us understand the form of
this PDF by focusing first on
the exponent, exactly
as we did for the
standard normal case.
The exponent is a quadratic, and
that quadratic is centered
at x equal to mu.
So it vanishes when x
is equal to mu, and
becomes positive elsewhere.
Then we take the negative
exponential of this quadratic,
and we obtain a function which
is largest at x equal to mu,
and falls off as we go
further away from mu.
What is the mean of this
random variable?
Since this term is symmetric
around mu, the PDF is also
symmetric around mu, and
therefore, the mean is also
equal to mu.
How about the variance?
It turns out--
and this is a calculus exercise
that we will omit--
that the variance of this PDF
is equal to sigma squared.
And this explains this
notation here.
We're dealing with a normal that
has a mean of mu and a
variance of sigma squared.
To get a little bit of
understanding of the role of
sigma in the form of this PDF,
let us consider the case where
sigma is small, and see how the
picture is going to change.
When sigma is small, and we
plot the quadratic, sigma
being small means that this
quadratic becomes larger, so
it rises faster, so we get
a narrower quadratic.
And in that case, the negative
exponential is going to fall
off much faster.
So when sigma is small, the PDF
that we get is a narrower
PDF, and that reflects itself
into the property that the
variance will also be smaller.
An important property of normal
random variables is
that they behave very nicely
when you form linear
functions of them.
And this is one of the reasons
why they're analytically
tractable and analytically
very convenient.
Here is what I mean.
Let us start with a normal
random variable with a given
mean and variance, and let us
form a linear function of that
random variable.
What is the mean of Y?
Well, we know what it is.
We have a linear function
of a random variable.
The mean is going to be a times
the expected value of X,
which is mu plus b.
What is the variance of Y?
We know what is the variance
of a linear function of a
random variable.
It is a squared times the
variance of X, which in our
case is sigma squared.
So there's nothing new so far,
but there is an additional
important fact.
The random variable Y, of
course, has the mean and
variance that we know it should
have, but there is an
additional fact--
namely, that Y is a normal
random variable.
So normality is preserved when
we form linear functions.
There's one special case that's
we need to pay some
attention to.
Suppose that a is equal to 0.
In this case, the random
variable Y is just equal to b.
It's a constant random
variable.
It does not have a PDF.
It is a degenerate discrete
random variable.
So could this fact be correct
that Y is also normal?
Well, we'll adopt this
as [a] convention.
When we have a discrete random
variable, which is constant,
it takes a constant value.
We can think of this as a
special degenerate case of the
normal with mean equal to b and
with variance equal to 0.
Even though it is discrete, not
continuous, we will still
think of it as a degenerate
type of a normal random
variable, and by adopting this
convention, then it will
always be true that a linear
function of a normal random
variable is normal, even
if a is equal to 0.
Now that we have the definition
and some properties
of normal random variables, the
next question is whether
we can calculate probabilities
associated with
normal random variables.
This will be the subject
of the next segment.